60 minutes correspondent Lesley Stahl
covered the White House for CBS News
during George HW Bush's time as
president and vice president in 1980 it
was Leslie who broke the news it mr.
Bush was chosen as Ronald Reagan's
running mate les he's challenged mr.
Bush's vice president and later as
president in the Oval Office after the
fall of the Berlin Wall
[Music]
you were lampooned to say the least
during the campaign for being so
supportive constantly loyal if you do
decide to run for president in 1988 well
won't that have hurt your image if you
continue along always being so
supportive and never standing out making
all surprised what would hurt my image
if I tried to say these are the good
things but I secretly told the president
that he shouldn't do this or that trying
to because somewhere along you trip over
something called character and I
couldn't do that to the president this
is a sort of degree for our side and the
big east-west battle but you don't seem
elated and I'm wondering if you're
thinking I'm elated I'm just not an
emotional kind of guy and Lesley Stahl
joins us you were in the room let's see
where it happened you to you and 41
seemed to have a lot of history together
integrity in class seemed to matter to
this man very much and you saw that it
was an 8
either it was an 8 or his mother pounded
it into him uh-huh but that little clip
about the Berlin Wall coming down
everybody in the world was well
everybody in the Western world was
celebrating that the wall had come down
people were dancing on top of the wall
and he summoned the White House pool
reporters into the Oval Office to make a
statement and he was sitting there just
glum everybody was elated and he was
kind of slumped and I asked him why and
the reason turned out to be and I think
Bob Gates told you earlier that he
didn't want to gloat and he didn't want
to you know rub Gorbachev's nose in the
fact that we had won the Cold War so
there was a you talked about integrity
he was decent mmm he was he had
compassion Henry Kissinger I once asked
Henry Kissinger what makes a great
leader and he said a great leader has to
have suffered has to have faced a trial
he certainly do that with the loss of
his daughter
exactly and I think that contributed to
his compassion and his depth as a human
being
you've covered a lot of white houses and
all that how is he different just in the
day-to-day of being in and around the
White House
well I covered Carter Reagan and Bush
and I never saw Carter or Reagan
wandering around the White House
you know poking into offices I
personally ran into him at least three
times in the first two years just
wandering and he would say hey how are
you auntie's towels snapping so he was a
person person if you know what I mean if
he was upset with the press would you
know it did you hear from all of it yeah
not personally but we knew it you know
we had a press secretary who was the
buffer but I got many notes and lovely
notes and they were all the kind of
notes you've heard from other reporters
you know all is forgiven kind of notes
same time yeah I was going to say one
other thing when I was covering the
White House Barbara Bush had a meeting
with this group of us and we had lunch
up in the living quarters and then she
gave us a tour and two things I'll never
forget one is that she brought us into
the Lincoln Bedroom it's the only time I
covered the White House for ten years
the only time I'd ever been in there and
there was a toy box
I mean grandchildren were a huge part of
his life he had a lot of them and they
came and stayed at the White House and
the toys were all over the place you
know he was real and he didn't try to
say he wasn't real and the other is that
Barbara took us to a window right up
there and she said look and she could
see right into the Oval Office she could
keep her eye on it if she wanted to and
she said that she told him what was on
her mind but she told him in the bedroom
right not not in the public domain what
was their relationship like to cover
from your vantage point well they were
so different she was she was terrific
you know authentic real she made a point
of saying these aren't real pearls it
was a big contrast with Nancy Reagan
from before and maybe Barbara even
made sure people understood the conflict
and he always made it seem that she was
the boss he talked about it but I think
she really was the boss he just talked
about it bipartisanship didn't seem to
be a bad word back then
oh well it's different time yeah of
course he was due he came out of the
World War two generation and they had a
code to live by that we don't seem to
have anymore which in my opinion is sad
mm-hmm
what's amazing quickly is that it's it's
Bush Walter when with that clip we saw
another thing is that Bush and Reagan
had fought like crazy in 1980 so that's
why it was such a great surprise that
just saluting and joining the team even
though he'd been at such you know it had
such bad fights with Reagan it's kind of
a metaphor for the way he conducted his
life all is forgiven I'm not going to
hold anything against you because that's
not my code that's not the rule the
moral rule that I live by and have to
live by and wanna live by and you have
to admire that he famously told Reagan
that I will never embarrass you as vice
president right Thank You Leslie for
coming this morning